argentina se unió a brasil méjico perú y
chile en la lista de países
latinoamericanos donde se detectaron
casos de la nueva variante del
coronavirus omicron tras este primer
caso en una persona que había viajado
desde sudáfrica el gobierno pidió a los
argentinos que se mantuvieran en alerta
a la verdad que me preocupa mucho porque
bueno es nada ya vivimos el tema de este
del hobbit que estar encerrados y todo y
la verdad que es nada se complica un
montón toda esta situación pero bueno
esperemos que no que no sea como la que
se fue no el primer país de la región en
anunciar un caso con esta pariente fue
brasil el alcalde de río de janeiro tomó
rápidamente medidas en contra de las
celebraciones de nochevieja la fiesta de
fin de año en el estado del río de
janeiro está lamentablemente cancelada
en mexico que también ya presenta casos
de omicron el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador anunció que este martes
comenzará la aplicación de dosis de
refuerzo de la vacuna contra el cob y 19
entre los adultos mayores
en perú ante su primer contagiado el
gobierno anunció que el carnet de
vacunación será obligatorio para los
mayores de 18 años que ingresen a
espacios cerrados como restaurantes y
comercios otro país que tomó medidas
para controlar el ingreso de la nueva
variante y fue ecuador he dispuesto que
se aplique la siguiente medida
prohibición de entrada al territorio
nacional a toda persona cuyo punto de
origen escala o tránsito sea la lista
específica de países del áfrica que
serán publicados por las autoridades
competentes
paraguay tomó medidas similares mientras
que argentina decidió únicamente ordenar
una cuarentena a las personas que vengan
de algún país de áfrica